mark which is important it's called mark
because it's modified gravity
right as opposed to modifying newtonian
dynamics
so you've got to have general route
you've got to have general relativity
okay so the big question everyone wants
to know and the experimentalists who are
watching this is do you make predictions
that agree
with the data okay
so back to this three phases of physics
have an idea guess it
mathematical formulation htvg
you publish it
now comes what i call
i call it physics his imagination in a
straight jacket
imagination the idea
the straight jacket is experimental
physics can you agree with experimental
physics can you predict something that
the other people can't fit
it's hard that's why physics is so hard
because
it
when i paint
uh i still paint
um there's no criteria you have to match
no i you i paint my i don't think
it's all left
it's all right brain more or less your
feelings
color composition
so i finished
put it up on the wall
and you either like it or you don't like
it you know i don't have to prove
anything i don't have to prove the
painting
you see
it's not physiological i don't want to
prove it just if you don't like it well
okay maybe you don't like this painting
but um in physics the test is to
experiment
and this is what makes physics so hard
it's very challenging that's why i like
it okay
so
uh okay moving forward
um
one paper after another
i've been publishing papers now
for 14 years htt stvg was published in
2006.
um so then in 2015
i published a pair long paper
uh on
mark black holes because i found a buy
all solution okay
and i call them marked black holes i
call them
schwarzschild
mog fly halls or kermark by hulker my
former
collaborator and friend
from
trinity and uh
there's been a lot of i've lost track
how many papers are published on more
play halls oh okay great because one of
my questions was what's the reception
like from the physics community
there must be i don't know i'm guessing
50 60 papers
that's a lot of citations
hundreds of citations in fact
i'm up to something like
seven thousand citations holy moly yeah
there's something called research gate
which is a portal
he was back on that so i'm up to
something like eleven thousand
yeah
so
a lot of people know me from my physics
but um
this paper i just sent you just from
chinese from china published yesterday
it's owned on the archive it'll be
published eventually it's a very
very good paper
because i published in my big paper
on mark black halls
published the european physical journal
c
and this is a major european journal
in
2016
and subsequent papers
uh i
published a a
solution of my modified gravity theory
for an object
which may not have horizons
and it's regular it does not have any
singularity at the center
it's completely irregular
interesting
but it's close to having a horizon
because there's a critical
in in the development there's a free
parameter called alpha
in the mathematics of the
the metric
describing my marked black hole
and this alpha is a deviation parameter
it deviates
the theory from einstein
black holes
the size of alpha when alpha zero
you get
einstein black holes
when half is not zero you don't okay
so in addition to the
black hole with the horizon
actually
my solution mark
always has two horizons
and the parameters are just mass and
spin and alpha three parameters that's
it
so